back everyone to our final talk of today
and the final Talk of the room in P
data today we have two speakers Tony
becknell and Chris holder Tony has been
working as a professor of computer
science first at the University of East
Anglia where he was supervising the PHD
student Chris holder and now more
recently he's moved to the University of
Southampton together they have also
worked on the package Aon which they
will be discuss in today for time series
so let's give all a warm welcome to Tony
and
Chris the floor is
yours thank you good morning thank you
bit
echoey okay so we're here today to talk
to you about uh some work we've been
doing with uh distance functions for
time series now this is all part of the
Aon package Aon not Eon big debate about
that uh and this package is an open
source python toolkit SK uh SK learn
compatible that grew out of a project
with the Alan churing Institute and is
uh now funded by the UK government
through the epsrc scheme in order to
promote uh Research In Time series for
science now the ethos behind it Aon is
to try and reduce the time it takes
between people like me coming up with
ideas for how to do time series machine
learning and people who practitioners
using it right we want to reduce that
pipeline you know you read a paper
we write papers we try and look really
clever we put in loads of math you think
that seems like a great idea but how do
you use it right we want to shorten that
development time from coming up with an
idea to people being able to utilize it
now my normal crowd is either
undergraduates or academics right so
it's the first time I talked to a p data
event so I not quite sure how to pitch
it so if I get it wrong do let me know
and feedback for next time um I'm going
to start off just giving some motivation
and background grounded to time series
machine learning this is my research
field so I'm going to give a very high
level overview of the types of problem
we address in Time series machine
learning and the types of data sets we
use to evaluate our
algorithms we'll end that with
motivating why we need distance
functions and why we need time series
specific distance functions so I'm going
to describe some of these functions and
how they actually operate
algorithmically uh before Chris steps in
and introduces his implementations which
is part of his PhD uh which would
describe how we actually use them uh
with data finally if there's time we'll
talk a little bit about a paper we just
have published which lead author on
using distance functions for clustering
time series
clustering so very very basic what do we
mean by a Time series or what do I mean
in terms of my research by a Time series
key points about a time series for us
are they're ordered now the ordering
usually is in time but it doesn't need
to be the specific characteristic that
makes it a Time series is the ordering
is important right so you can't reindex
all your time series and still use the
same algorithm and still learn the same
things from your data we focus
specifically on real valued time series
okay so we you can obviously you can
have categorical time series but my
research focuses purely on real valued
series and these occur in all areas of
Science and business right uh just in
terms of terminology we say if we have a
single variable observed in an ordered
way over time here such as GDP we call
this a univariant and if we
have multiple time series that are
aligned such as here we have an EEG scan
uh we call that a multivariate problem
and we refer to each time series as a
channel just so we clear about what
we're talking about right time series
machine learning most people when when
they think about time series analysis
they think about forecasting right
forecasting is a huge field massive
econometrics and everyone's business is
driven by forecasting and there's a
whole host of algorithms around it many
of which have developed from statistics
uh now everyone's throwing deep learning
at it etc etc this isn't my primary area
of Interest what I'm interested in is
more General machine learning so the
classical machine learning problems of
clustering classification and regression
all occur in Time series I'll give you a
few examples of these in the subsequent
slides but if we have a collection of
Time series and a label then we may want
to build a machine learning model on it
right a predictive model that predicts
something that isn't just the future
values of the
series you also have time series
specific uh component uh problems things
like anomaly detection in Time series
right is very different to anomaly
detection in tabular data query by
content rule Discovery and Motif
Discovery but my main research the theme
is coming up and what my group do we
come up with algorithms for uh
clustering classification and regression
that are specific to time series because
if you just use standard offthe shelf
machine learning algorithms they do not
perform as well because they do not
allow for the time dependent data so
when we come up with these algorithms
right what we do is think of a clever
way of doing something under some use
case uh and then we evaluate it right
and in machine learning generally we
like using real world problems to
evaluate our data set on so some of the
problems we use are part of uh a
repository of data sets you know you've
got UCI has a standard repository for
machine learning UCR University of
California Riverside hosts some generic
data sets which are used for time series
classification and the evaluation of
algorithms right so when we get to the
end we going to compare some different
algorithms and when we do that we
evaluate them on this very diverse wide
range of data
sets uh I host them on this on the
website time series
classification. in collaboration with
Riverside and the regression problems we
also host and that's in collaboration
with
MES so this has been ongoing development
right aan first proposed it in 2002
we've expanded it we've donated problems
for data sets which we''ve
[Music]
uh uh We've obtained from scientific
collaborations basically so we work with
people time series are everywhere we
work with people in spectrograms and
with medical when they have a data if
they can release it as an open source
data set we put it in a repository and
people use them to evaluate their
algorithms just a quick brief overview
of the types of data we host uh and the
types of problems I'm particularly
interested in EEG at the moment so EEG
data you are people's heads up you
record the electrical activity there's a
host of machine learning issues problems
that derive from EEG one of which we're
looking at is the detection early onset
dementia right so we're working with
people in Cambridge they want a
lowcost uh machine learning based
algorithm for running an EG on someone
and seeing if they may be at early risk
of dementia because the earlier you
treat it the better the outcomes EG is
also used in BCI right can I detect
whether someone's moving their arm or
even thinking about moving their arm uh
it's also used a lot in Psychology but
the key point is they get a whole bunch
of these data we've got labels how do we
build a predictive model given this sort
of data
set it's everywhere time series data is
everywhere I cannot talk to anyone in
any area of science or even business and
they've all got time series most people
don't use bespoke techniques of them
they just kind of do some you know uh
General data engineering which is they
think would be a good idea and they
don't follow a good scientific method
for evaluating techniques so all sorts
of sensors and uh human activity
recognition is another area we're
interested in everyone's wired up right
you detect people's Motion in the XY Z
and also
acceleration what can you do with that
data there's whole host of applications
such as detecting if people fall over in
the home all the old Internet of Things
stuff there's loads of research groups
around the country around the world
really who researching
algorithms that build predicted models
of this type of data now at the heart of
any
system that uses time series in machine
learning you very often want to measure
the similarity between series okay I've
got two time series a fundamental
question is how alike are they now in
your simplest use Case Model you could
use a classifier right you could use a
one nearest neighbor classifier here's a
Time series series I find this closest
one in my data set and I use that label
as my prediction but you measure
distance between time series all the
time right so fundamental in a whole
host of algorithms is this thing if I
got one time series how similar is it to
another and the question we're talking
about today is how do we measure that if
you give me two time series I want to
quantify how similar they
are now
similarity is subjective right so the
the heart of it the the essence of
saying this thing is like that one kind
of defines what you mean by to be like
it right when we see it sometimes it's
obvious okay I can say these two things
are very alike they got the same shirt
same trousers they look kind of the same
right so most people would agree that if
I'm going to quantify the similarity
between these two objects I would have
high similarity or small distance right
the distance between them is small
however
sometimes it's more difficult right so
if I give you these two images you can
say are they alike well in one level
they are very alike right the similarity
is is high however on a fundamental
level they are not alike right so when
and this relates to time series as well
what do we mean for two time series to
be similar and when we talk about
elastic distances this is crucially what
we're going to compensate for is how
standard similarity falls down when we
think things are quite
similar now measuring similarity is
basically comes down to excuse
me uh a distance function right
fundamental operation is I have two time
series and I want to measure how far
apart they are simplest distance
function it's ukian distance right we
just measure the distance between the
points Square them and add them up uh
and take square root and that gives us a
standard distance function everyone's
probably familiar
with there are many other standard
distance functions available in CI and
and all these packages we could
generalize it to the Makowski distance
we could talk about Manhattan distance
or correlation the key point about all
these distance functions is that you
could reindex your two series and they
would be the same right there's no shape
characteristic in this data in this
measurement if we look
here you know we're going to say that
these two time series are quite similar
cuz they both got a hump now if I
reindexed it and I put the the the peak
of one at the beginning the other at the
end ukan distance would be the same and
what we want to do with an elastic
distance is compensate for that to
actually come up with a measure that
says well these are quite alike but
they're slightly off an
index so just to motivate that a bit
more why do we need an elastic distance
so here's Three Time series
series 1 and two are with the Peaks and
series three is is the one through the
middle now intuitively on my notion of
similarity I would say series one is
more like series two the two peak ones
than is Series 3 but if I measure ukian
distance of these two time series we
find that the distance between 1 and two
is greater distance between 1 and
three what an elastic distance measure
does is realigns them so it compensates
for that so that our similarity between
1 and two is greater that is our
distance is smaller than it is between 1
and 3 and two and
three right so
uh as always I'm going to um speed this
up a bit if we look at the pointwise
distance between Series so now I'm just
going to motivate how Dynamic time
warping works right this algorithm
so if we look at the point ways distance
we see by going through the indexes
along the diagonal we reach these big
two distances which is the distance
between this point here and this point
here what if we could realign it what if
instead of going down the diagonal we
could just shift and move 0 4 onto 0.
five and that's essentially what
elastics distances do is they realign
the series so that our
measure allows for this small out of
phase
Index this is the algorithm for DTW
essentially we generate this cost Matrix
and then the final distance to the end
is our Dynamic time warping distance
it's a dynamic programming formulation
but it's really quite simple all we do
is each point is we look for the minimum
of round there and then we add in the
pointwise
distance and what this does uh just bit
of code here CH we show a bit more is
essentially it shifts the index of these
points to align them better and now we
see that if we
have uh the distance between one and
three is greater than on the previous
example I shown you than the distance
between these
two okay that's the essence of what's
going on it's it's allowing compensating
for small phase misalignments by
Shifting the
indexes wildly popular the only example
I've got on here is from another core
developer Aon works for helion uh make
toothpaste and they he just he sent a
link to this the other day so I put it
up there um but you will see Dynamic
time warping is a fundamental operation
used very widely it came out of speech
research 50 years ago right became less
popular in speech but it is still
considered the standard way of uh
measuring distance between time series
if you're going to have some
misalignment
there is however host of alternative
approaches based on edit distance this
idea of warping moving the index to one
to the other there's a another theme of
research that looks at editing that is
removing a series to form a combined one
now this is pretty standard if you're
looking at discrete series uh
particularly DNA and things like this
edit distance is just how do you
transform from one to another and
there's a whole bunch of research that's
described how you could adapt this
massive body of literature towards real
value time
series uh so what edit distances do is
that um rather than say well let's warp
it onto one they they do the similar
operations but say what what if we
delete it or insert it now I'm not got
time to go through in great detail about
how these algorithms work uh but I
should just do one very quickly analogy
from one to the other and introduce one
algorithm which we found to be most
effective so essentially what you're
doing is you're rephrasing the problem
of DTW is diagonal moving up or down as
having a match which is move on diagonal
and insert which is moving one axis
delete is moving the other and you have
a cost associated with each of these
operations so just as when you edit
distance a word if you change a letter
right that has a cost associated with it
this is the similar thing we're doing
with elastic
distances okay uh I'm just going to talk
about move split merge so essentially uh
this algorithm was proposed about 10
years ago uh not by us it's someone else
and what this does is it replaces that
pointwise measure the M there is a
pointwise distance between I and J with
the cost function
okay now again the slides will be
available I've got an example of how it
works but essentially what it does
rather than just use a pointwise
distance when it's doing the warping it
looks at the three series and sees what
would happen if we removed that piece
so the cost associated with MSM is all
about what if I took that data point out
of the calculation or indeed put one
into the other one okay so I always talk
on too much but I should now hand over
to Chris who will describe some of the
distance functions that are available in
a yeah so we've just seen the theory for
elastic distances and edit distances and
they're pretty complicated at times so
what we've tried to do in Aon is make it
really simple for you to use and
understand them and we've done that
through both optimizing our
documentation and making our API
compatible with other languages such as
sklearn they seem very familiar to you
so our documentation our API is on Aon
tool kit.org and we spend a lot of time
working on this and there's some really
good examples on there if you want
details in the future um but we offer a
wide range of elastic distances and
regular distances in Aon all of which
can be used in the same way
so we support for all of them we support
univariate multivariate and unequal
length when we say unequal length it's
when you have two time series which one
may have a recording that lasts a day
longer than the previous one which is
quite common in the real world that your
time series will not be the same length
so we've put a real priority on making
it work for unequal length we've also
optimized them using number so they can
perform especially on the cloud and so
your server bills don't go through the
roof so we have gone with very simple
API you would if you've used either
scipi or SK learned distances we follow
the exact same format you can either
import our distances uh directly so DTW
distance or you can use a utility
function and specify your two time
series and then a metric string so in
this instance we have DTW so your time
series are just X and Y and you get a
single floating Point number which is
the distance between the two time series
which uses the elastic
distances you can also have parameters
for a lot of these and I'm not going to
go into all of them today but they're
all on our documentation a window is a
warping window is a common one one to
restrict how far the elastic distance
can walk um and you can just specify
these by passing a keyword argument of
window to it and again this is all
documented in great detail on our API um
but we also have uh alignment pment API
we've decided to open this up as well
normally this is kept closed so in TS
learn it's quite hard to get the
alignment paths uh if you need them for
other things such as averaging um so
we've also have our API open for the
alignment paths and you can use all the
elastic distances to get there alignment
parts and again they all work for
unequal length for multivariate um and
you can use them in the exact same way
where we just we can import it directly
so this is MSN or we can use the utility
function and in this instance you get
two return values the first value is
your alignment path and your second
value is the distance in case you need
it um and all that shows is a list of
tups where it shows which point in the
first time series warps to the second
point in the second time series so then
you can use other other functions I'm
sorry this is just with parameters you
can can use our other functions in the
library to plot your alignment paths so
you can see exactly where your time
series are warping for your use case
which is really important if you want to
use this is you want to go okay does it
make sense that my my my warping path is
warping is it too free is it warping all
over the place maybe then I should add a
window parameter to it to stop it going
all over the
place so finally as our API we also have
pairwise distance functions now this is
when you have a collection or a data set
of Time series and you want say Okay I
want to measure the distance between
every single value in my data set
between every other value so you know
the distance between them and this is
really common um and we support all of
these um all of our elastic distances
and our our non-elastic distances we
don't have support for unequal length
for this yet um but they we're hoping to
get this in the new version of uh Aon um
coming soon um so again we this time we
specify a data set so there's just fre
time series in this data set and we say
what's the pair tww pairwise distance
and we get a matrix back which is every
combination of distance now if you are
doing more than one distance computation
at once you're going to want to use
these pairwise distances because they've
been optimized for doing it over data
sets so you can do it between one data
set or you can specify two data sets and
say what is the distance between these
data sets and you get a similar result
you can also use the parameters as
normal by specifying keyword
argument and you can use them with SK
learn which I think is quite important
and your other models so a common way
you would do that is you have a
pre-computed argument and this is where
you provide a pre-computed pairwise so
in this instance we pre-compute our pair
wise distance Matrix and we pass it to
the fit of our svm model here and we
pass it to our score or I guess your
predict and you can use these with
sklearn models as well um you can also
directly pass the pairwise function
instead of doing a pre-computed so here
we pass the MSM pairwise function as the
kernel and that just makes your code a
bit more more concise and cleaner and it
should all work with sklearn and other
libraries so you can also use it this
just another example with clustering
module as well to show that it works
across modules this is pre-computed
again just pass our pair wise Matrix to
fit and then we get our labels out and
you can do make it more concise Again by
just passing in directly the pair wise
Matrix um so that's the uh just a code
example so I'm going to pass back to
Tony just to finish so just to wrap up
I'm just going to introduce uh this
paper which was published uh this month
Chris is part of Chris's PhD and really
just to address why do we need these
other distance functions what's the
point if we've got DTW why do we need
other elastic distance functions so
Chris implemented them all we ran them
all on those archive data sets I
mentioned before so we got 112 we do 30
resample maybe we didn't on this anyway
we we run them on all and we compare
basic classification algorithms using
this distance function so most people
remember use DTW we found that
DTW was significantly worse at
clustering than ukian distance right
this surprised us uh because everyone
uses it right uh but MSN and another Al
called TW we was significantly better
there were reasons for this gone into
great depth in the paper which we shall
uh which I encourage you to read
um but it shows that they are finding
different things now there's a rationale
for doing this this with K means
clustering which is very stand form of
clustering we also looked at kids uh and
various differences uh but the the
take-home message from this comparative
analysis was actually if we're
clustering time series with a distance
function standard clustering algorithms
you are better off using one of the edit
distance based ones like move split
merge than Dynamic time warping now it's
not to say Dynamic time warping isn't
hugely useful and Brilliant and
fantastic uh you know it took us a year
and a half to get this published because
the reviewers thought it was brilliant
and fantastic and how could it be better
but what we're saying is there are use
cases for different
distances okay I'm not talking about
barri Center averaging because that's a
whole talk in
itself uh so okay I think that's about
my time um uh what I say is Aon is an
open source project we we do have a
full-time developer funded by the
government and myself working on it
we're very keen on collaborations part
of the reason for coming here you know
we focus most on science and academics
but we want to broaden it out and we
would welcome everyone's contribution
distance function is quite good way of
doing that a whole host of other
distance functions and distance function
based algorithm so if you want to get
involved please get in touch okay thank
you